es sei aber kein diktator wie wladimir
putin oder zum beispiel der syrische
präsident assad der millionen von
menschen in seinem land getötet hat also
ich finde es doch gefährlich zu sagen
dass dann schon gefährlicher ist als
putin oder assad oder terroristen die
welt bedrohen
wenn wir diese metrik nehmen und ich
sage nicht dass es eine große mädchen
ist wenn wir diese metrik ansetzen und
sagen gewalt und verlorene leben dann
natürlich ist dann hat putin oder stadt
habe mehr schaden angerichtet als ein
ganzes land zerstört aber ist das
wirklich das einzige kriterium es ist
einzige maßstab den wir uns anschauen
denn noch einmal amerika bis vor kurzem
war das mächtigste land auf dem planet
das reichste land auf dem planeten es
war ein land was enorm viel einfluss
hatte weltweit gesehen das heißt all das
hatte verändert dort hat das alles
verringert er hat seine eigenen menschen
in gefahr gebracht
er hat die westliche allianz er ist aus
dem pariser klimaabkommen ausgezogen
ausgestiegen roth die sicherheit des
planeten und deswegen glaube ich dass
wir darüber ganz klar sprechen müssen
und es klar benennen müssen er versucht
jetzt ein klug zu inszenieren
das ist vielleicht mein hatte ich das
hört sich so an aber was müssen wir ganz
klar sehen was passiert ist denn wenn
wir das nicht tun dann werden wir gucken
da stelle ich verstehe natürlich dass es
so erscheinen kann dass es dass ich zu
melodramatisch bin dass ich den fall zu
groß darstelle
aber wie sich das gesamte bild sehen
dann kann ich sehen dass wir nicht
streiten können dass dort schon
gefährlich mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schaue ich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren